- Heading back to Colorado to go skiing
and I was able to figure a
way to put a layover in L.A.
so I can stop and hangout
with Lizz for the day
and hopefully surprise her
at her work at Buzzfeed.
- I think I got an olympian
to go on a date with me.
His name is Robbie.
(upbeat music)
- I decided to come down here to L.A.
cause we had such a fun
time in South Korea.
I thought why not keep playing with it,
talking with her and
see how everything goes.
So today's goal is just to have fun,
enjoy each other's company
and then hopefully at the end of the day,
maybe get a kiss.
Nah, just Robbie.
- Oh, it's just Robbie.
- Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Hey, hey.
(laughs)
Hey, I was wondering if it'd be possible
to take Lizz out on our second date today.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Robbie] Please!
- We're just leaving?
- [Boss] Yeah, I mean go, go, go, go.
- (laughs) Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm just, like, I'm just like in shock.
- Hello!
- This is Robbie.
I met him at the Olympics.
(laughs) I know!
- This is an amazing love story
and I'm just so here for it.
- Do you know where you're going?
- Yeah, we're gonna go that way!
I thought it'd be super
fun to go surfing today.
- I went surfing once when I was little
so I'm definitely not gonna be as good
as the pro right here
but, you know, we'll see.
- They're super down.
They're like, whatever, just have fun.
Enjoy yourself.
It's my life
They're not like, "get married."
Saying, obviously I have
a lot of things I'm trying
to do right now so it's not...
It's more just right now, just have fun.
Enjoy the moment.
Don't overthink it.
Just, you know, live.
- Robbie and I are headed to the beach.
We're chatting in the car
and everything's going well.
He's really easy to talk to
and is also very smooth.
Not as smooth as me,
but you know. (scoffs)
- [Robbie] Lizz, check this out.
(laughs)
- Ha, ha! I get to see it again!
- No!
- I'm so excited to go out
with Lizz on the waves.
We'll see how it goes.
- He's ready to get destroyed by me.
Like, literally the wind blew my board
off course when I was walking
so I can only imagine how
this is gonna go in the water.
(upbeat music)
Surfing is (bleep) harder than it looks.
The waves look super tame and super chill
but actually, when you're out there,
they're (bleep) intense.
- Yeah!
(laughs)
I'm exhausted, super fun though.
I'm pumped that Lizz is out here
getting up on some of the waves.
(grunts) The training.
- Just got done surfing with Robbie.
- While we're out there, we were able
to get a little bit of time together
but not enough to squeeze a kiss in
so that was kinda a bummer.
I'm hoping for the next
section of this date
that maybe I could find the
time to squeeze a kiss in.
- So what's next for you?
Are you waiting to hear back
from places or something?
- Yeah, either a company in Florida
or a company in Washington D.C.
Mom, I mean Lizz, chill
out on the job stuff, okay?
I have tons of time to go live my life,
get a job and grow up, okay?
- Well, this was such an amazing date
and I really hope that I
get to see again one day.
- I hope so too.
This is super fun and
let's just stay in contact
and see where it goes.
- Okay.
- Yeah?
- I'll see you later.
- [Lizz] Thank you so much
- [Robbie] See you soon.
- [Lizz] See you soon.
You know I'm not totally
sure of Robbie's intentions.
It seems like he just wants
to have fun and live life
where as I am very focused on my career
and I live in L.A. and I'm
not going all over the place
as much as he is and figuring out
where I'm gonna be living.
So, you know, we're at these two
very different stages of our life.
I really like spending time with him.
I just really don't know
what's going to happen next.
(smooth music)